hi as you can see a little situation
here of my arm here I was wrestling
around my son who's a hundred and eighty
pounds in the kitchen as my wife has
telling me not to wrestle in the kitchen
he went back his head was going to hit
the back of the stove I grabbed him and
I braced my left arm as hard as I could
and I just snapped my humerus basically
the humerus should be like this mine's
like that so I went to the ER went
through a lot of extreme pain now I have
a lot more sympathy for people are in
severe pain because that was the most
excruciating pain I've ever felt in my
life and now I know what my wife feels
like when she said she was pregnant but
probably not to that degree but anyway I
went to the ER was fractured so then now
I had to wait over the weekend to get
surgery which I was not excited about
but I could had to get a plate on my
shoulder that went from here to here
because the rotator cuffs also
dispatched from the bone and they had to
nail those back somehow so they have
screws and bolts and all sorts of things
in there so on Monday morning I went in
at 8 o'clock and I finally get in got in
to the surgery at 12 so here's another
interesting experience I hate waiting in
doctors offices so now I'm on the other
end I'm the guy waiting and so now I'm
never gonna let any patients wait
because I've done that in the past so
I'm definitely learning some interesting
experiences here but so what happened
was we went into surgery and it was like
like a minute later I was just waking up
and I looked at the clock and it was
three hours later so it went really fast
so I was happy about that but as I as my
wife took me home my blood pressure was
really low so I got home went to bed and
I just could not urinate which is one of
the side effects of the medication I was
heavily drugged
so about 3 o'clock in the morning I had
enough I told my wife take me to the ER
right now be
I haven't gone the bathroom so all that
toxic waste in your body so I went to
back to the hospital wait in an hour
and they evaluated me and they said well
we're going to put a full
catheterization and you and I'm like
what is that they go oh don't worry
about it's just going to be some slight
pressure
I was another painful experience so they
took out a liter of fluid from my body
which was pleasurable to get that out
but then they I had this thing inside me
that was even more uncomfortable because
they taped this bag to my leg which I
was walking out of there going this is
not going to work so I had them take it
retake it out and I said just let me go
home I just want to go home so I go home
and give me all these drugs to take and
they were like saying yeah you have to
take these drugs but I remembered there
was a remedy that I used on some
patients in the past called chlorophyll
pearls which is this thing right here
chlorophyll is like liquid but like the
blood of the plant it's like liquid
sunshine it detoxifies the things that
cause pain at the nerve endings so as
soon as I got that in my body like the
pain just went right away so I really
have not taken any medication so it's
been two days after the surgery and uh I
have no pain in my arm at all so it's
healing fast I'm doing the acupressure
on it so I will keep you updated and how
things go but this was definitely an
interesting experience that I don't want
to experience everybody can't talk to
you later